Ukraine says at least one person has
been killed in the Odessa region after
Russia launched a missile and drone
attack early on Wednesday Ukraine's
military says the aerial bombardment on
the danu port lasted for hours and
damaged agricultural facilities used for
grain exorts well let's bring in Rob
McBride he's in cvy re for us Rob this
was a three-hour long
attack yeah these attacks tend to last
for a couple of hours each time and we
have seen these nightly attacks a number
of times in the past few weeks once
again it was these uh River Port
facilities based in the south of the
adessa region feeding into the danu
river system that were targeted in
particular the port city of Ismael
number of facilities grain uh grain
storage facilities and handling
facilities were damaged uh we are
getting reports of casualties at least
one person is said to have been killed
he died of his injuries later uh in uh
hospital but we've seen these kind of
attacks taking place pretty much
consistently for more than a month now
ever since the cancellation of the Black
Sea grain deal back in July there have
been other attacks overnight as well the
uh ukrainians say a total of more than
30 uh projectiles be they Crews
ballistic missiles or drones were
targeted at Ukraine overnight some of
them down around the danu but also at ke
the capital itself the air defenses were
working
uh during the early hours of the morning
round about Daybreak these attacks on ke
usually happen during the hours of
Darkness at least more recently they
have been doing so uh but again there
were attacks on ke air defenses were
working at uh Daybreak uh and it's been
more than a week now uh since we've had
an attack on the capital itself Rob
around o Desa it looks like it was a lot
of of grain export infrastructure that
was damaged after that meeting with
Putin and erdogan where are we now on
the grain
deal
yeah there does seem to be a certain
amount of ambivalence here in Ukraine
just about this whole grain deal there
is uh a lot of cynicism about renewing
this grain deal and about the importance
of it and about uh whether in in trying
to renew this grain deal without giving
too many concessions to the Russians
there would certainly be push back from
ukrainians uh about that because in any
case over the many months that we
they've been struggling to export their
grain through the Black Sea the
ukrainians have found alternative routs
these roots down uh the River ports that
feed into the danu and then to
neighboring Rania uh through uh the the
corridor there also through land routs
but they've also been trying to operate
uh this uh sea Corridor of their own
from adessa across the Black Sea and we
haven't had many ships using that but
over the weekend two more vessels
managed to make the journey safely to uh
Romania and to Bulgaria from adessa
that's without any gar
from the Russians so there do seem to be
alternatives to that and then also there
is the view here in Ukraine that you
know Vladimir Putin talking about
feeding the hungry of Africa at on the
stage in in Suchi if he was really
genuine about that then people here
would say well maybe he should stop uh
destroying the grain exporting
facilities that Ukraine has on the danub
River from Big briad there with the
latest for us from cvy Reed thank you so
much Rob